Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss.
And welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I'm gonna start off as I often do with a quote.
This is from one of my favorite writers of all time,
Kurt Vonnegut.
And it goes as follows,
quote,
here is a lesson in creative writing.
First rule,
do not use semi-colons.
They're transvestite.
Hermaphrodites representing absolutely nothing.
All they do is show that you've been to college.
And quote,
I have a habit of using dashes in the same way.
So I like to read this,
to remind me not to use that crutch.
Also pretty the adverb,
I overuse that.
So in any case,
Kurt Vonnegut,
lots of lessons,
uh,
lots of amazing books.
If you need one to start with,
go with cat's cradle.
Today's guest is Kevin Kelly.
Kevin Kelly is one of the most interesting human beings I've ever met.
He's a dear friend.
And as for the bio,
Kevin Kelly is senior maverick at wired magazine,
which he co founded in 1993.
He also cofounded the all Species Foundation,
a nonprofit aimed at cataloging and identifying every living species on earth.
And in all his spare time,
he writes bestselling books.
He cofounded the Rosetta project,
which is building an archive of all documented human languages and he serves on
the board of the long now foundation,
uh,
which I've been honored to join as a speaker on one occasion as part of the long
now foundation he's looking into,
among other things,
how to revive and restore endangered or extinct species,
including the woolly mammoth.
I'm not making this stuff up.
Kevin is amazing.
This is going to be a multipart episodes,
so there'd be a number of different podcasts episodes because we went quite
long.
This is part one.
I hope you enjoy it.
You can find all links,
show notes,
and so on once we complete the entire series@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash
podcast you can also find all previous episodes I've done in this podcast,
four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast,
all spelled out,
and without further ado,
please enjoy and thank you for listening
at this altitude.
I can flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living to show what method.
Kevin,
thank you so much for being on the show.
It's my honor
and I am endlessly fascinated by all of the varied projects that you constantly
have going on.
But that leads me to the first question,
which is when you meet someone who is not familiar with your background and they
ask you the age old,
what do you do?
Question,
how do you even begin to answer that?
What is your stock answer to that
these days?
My stock answer is,
is that I package ideas into books and magazines and websites,
and I make ideas interesting and pretty
well,
I like to pretty,
that's cool.
We'll come back to the aesthetic aspect.
I think that's a really neglected piece of the entire puzzle.
You do have,
of course,
a background.
A lot of people are familiar with your background with wired,
but perhaps you could give folks a bit of of background on yourself.
And is it true that you,
you dropped out of college after one year?
Yeah,
I'm a college dropout and actually my one regret in life is that one year.
Oh,
no kidding.
No kidding.
I wish I had even skip that,
but I,
I do understand how college can be useful to people and I have my own children
have gone through,
but for me it was just not the right thing.
And I went to Asia instead and I like to tell myself that I gave my own self a
Phd in East Asian studies by traveling around and photographing very remote
remote parts of Asia at a time when it was in a transition from the ancient
world to the modern world.
And I did many other things as well.
And for me it was a very formative time because I did enough things that when I
finally got my first real job at the age of 35
Oh wow.
I worked for a nonprofit at $10 an hour,
which was the whole earth catalog,
which we had been in that kind of a lifelong dream.
If I said,
if I wouldn't have a job,
that's the job I want.
It took me a long time to kind of get it.
But in between that I did many things including starting businesses and selling
businesses and doing other kinds of things,
more adventures and I highly recommend it.
You know,
I got involved in starting wired and running wired for a while and,
and uh,
hired a lot of people who were coming right out of college.
There were interns and they would do the intern thing and then there were good
and we would hire them,
which meant that basically you don't have to 10 years,
whatever it was they were,
this was their first and only job.
And I kept telling them,
why are you here?
What are you doing?
You should be fooling around wasting time trying something crazy.
Why are you working a real job?
I don't understand it.
And I just really,
I really recommend slack.
I'm a big believer in,
in this thing of kind of doing something that's not productive,
you know,
practice or your Middle Ages Young,
want to be prolific and make and do things,
but you don't want to measure them in terms of productivity.
You,
you want to measure them in terms of extreme performance.
Do you want to measure them in kind of,
um,
extreme satisfaction?
It's a time to kind of try stuff and,
and I think explore the extremes.
Exactly.
Explore the possibilities and there's so many possibilities and there's more
every day and you don't want,
it's called premature organization.
You,
you really,
you really want to use this time to continue to do things.
And by the way,
premature optimization is a problem of success.
It's not just the problem with the young,
it's the problem of the successful more than even at the end.
But we'll get to that.
Yeah,
that's that.
That's a long answer.
That might turn into a therapy session for me at this precise moment in time.
In fact.
Exactly.
But when you are exploring that slack,
I would imagine many people feel pressured,
whether it's internal pressure or societal,
familial pressure to get a real job to support themselves.
And there are a lot of the decisions are made out of fear.
They worry about being out on the streets or it's a nebulous terror anxiety.
How did you support yourself,
for instance,
while you were traveling through Asia?
When,
when,
when you left school,
I totally understand this anxiety and fear and stuff,
but here's,
here's the thing.
I think one of the many kind of life skills that you want to actually learn it
at a fairly young age is the skill of being like ultra thrifty,
minimal kind of this little whisper,
this traveling through time and the sense of learning how little you actually
need to live,
not just in kind of um,
survival mode but it kind of,
you know,
in a contented mode.
And I learned that pretty early by backpacking and doing other things and
especially in Asia was I could be very happy with very,
very little and you can go onto websites and stuff and look at sort of like the
minimum amount of stuff,
food say that you need to to live,
you know,
your basic protein and carbohydrates and vitamins and,
and how much you actually,
if you were bought them in bulk,
how much it would cost.
I mean you build your own house,
live in a shelter,
a tiny house,
you don't need very much.
And I think trying that out,
you know,
building your house on the pond,
like the row who's a hero of mine in high school is a not just a simple exercise
is so profound exercise because it allows you to get over the anxiety even if
you aren't living like that,
you know that if the worst came to worst,
you could keep going at a very low rate and be content.
And so that gives you the sort of confidence to take a risk because you say,
what's the worst that can happen?
Well,
the worst has happened is that I'd have a backpack and a sleeping bag and that'd
be eating oatmeal and you know,
whatever.
You know,
and that'd be fine.
Yeah.
And I think if you do that once or twice,
you don't necessarily have to live like that,
but,
but knowing that you can be content is tremendously empowering.
That's what I did.
That's basically what I did.
It was,
you know,
living in Asia where the people around me had less than I did and they were
pretty content.
We realized,
oh my gosh,
I don't really need very much to be happy.
And did you save up money beforehand with odd jobs or did you do odd jobs while
on the road?
A bit of both.
I did odd jobs before I left.
I was traveling in Asia at a time when the price differential was so great that
it actually made sense for me to fly back on a charter flight to the u s and
work for four or five months.
And I worked basically odd jobs.
I worked from working in a warehouse,
packaging,
uh,
athletic shoes,
working in a kind of technical sense of,
uh,
it's a really just hard to describe what it was.
It was kind of a,
in a photography related job where we reducing printed circuit boards down to
little sizes to be shipped off to be printed and driving cars to whatever else I
could find.
And that at that time made more money I could live off of.
I could live a probably two years from those couple months of work.
So I didn't really work while I was traveling until I got to Iran in the late
seventies and there there was a very high paying job,
which was teaching English to the Iranian pilots who worked for the shop,
but I had sworn there was never going to teach English,
so I actually got a job in Bella Hah helicopter who was teaching English is to
the pilots,
but my job was running a little newsletter for the American community there and
I worked there until I was thrown out by the coup.
That was another story.
Just a couple of comments.
So number one,
for those people listening who are saying to themselves already perhaps creating
reasons why they can't do what you did.
Now do you do different economic climate or whatnot?
It is entirely possible to replicate what you did.
You just have to choose your locations wisely for that,
for the type of differential.
And I should also just mention the people that part of the reason that I'm so
attracted to stoic philosophy,
whether that be Seneca or Marcus Aurelius is exactly because of the practice of
poverty,
not because you want to be poor,
but so that you recognize not only that you can subsist,
but then you can potentially be content or,
or even in some cases be more content with a bare minimum.
So for people who were more interested in that,
I highly recommend a lot of the stoic writings and you can search for those on
my blog and elsewhere.
But
let me just add to that.
There's actually a new age version of that that was sort of popular in a
generation ago.
And that search term there is a volunteer simplicity,
volunteer simplicity,
right?
And so the idea is poverty is terrible when it's mandatory,
when you have no choice.
But in volunteer version of that is very,
very powerful.
And I think attaching names sometimes to things,
it makes it more legitimate.
But imagine yourself practicing voluntary simplicity.
And that I think is part of that stoic philosophy,
but there was a whole kind of a movement allowed the,
it'd be dropouts were kind of practicing a similar thing and there was,
you know,
a whole best practices that resolved around that you can make up your own.
But I think it's to me an skill,
that life skill that people should choir and when you go backpacking and stuff
like that,
that's part of it.
That's the beginnings of trying to understand what it is that you need to live
as a,
you know,
as a being and you can fill that out in any way you want,
but that's a good way to experiment.
Now you have become a,
certainly a worldclass package or a of ideas,
but also at synthesizing and expressing these ideas.
I love your writing if I have consumed vast quantities of it.
In fact,
I'm here right now on on long island where I grew up and I used to sneak into my
parents' shed to read old additions of the whole earth catalog for inspiration.
It was,
it was the,
I suppose,
the equivalent of my internet at the time.
And from that all the way to 1000 true fans,
which of course,
you know,
I sort of shout from the rooftops for people to read.
How did you develop that skill of writing and communicating?
A lot of people associate that with schooling,
but it doesn't appear to be the source for you.
Yeah,
so in our school,
I would call myself a very late bloomer.
I,
I don't recall myself having a lot of ideas.
There were a lot of other people and kids in my high school that I was very
impressed with because they seem to know what they thought and we're very glib
and articulate and I,
and I,
and I wasn't,
I was a little bit more visual on that sense.
I was trying to decide whether to go to art school or to MIT because I was
really interested in science.
So I set off to Asia as a photographer.
So it was basically no words at all.
It was just images.
And as I was traveling and seeing these amazing things,
I mean,
again,
I want to emphasize that this was sort of a,
for me,
I grew up in New Jersey.
I had never left New Jersey.
We never took vacations.
It's hard to describe how parochial New Jersey was back in the 1960s I never ate
Chinese food and never had,
I mean,
I never saw a Chinese.
It was like it was a different world.
And then I was thrown into Asia and it was like,
oh my gosh,
everything I knew was wrong.
And so that education was extremely,
extremely powerful.
And I think that that,
that gave me something to say.
And I started writing letters home and I tried to describe what I was seeing.
And so I had a reason to try to communicate and that was the beginning of it.
But even then,
I don't think I really had much to say.
It wasn't really until the internet came along and I had a chance to go onto one
of the first online communities in the early eighties and for some reason
early eighties that is,
that is definitely,
yeah,
it was,
in 1981 and so this were private,
that wasn't the kind of wide open there and these were experiment.
In fact,
it was a New Jersey Institute of Technology in Rutgers to had this experimental
online community that I got invited on the night.
We can talk about how that happened,
but that was,
it was this,
this luck and a friend and I found that there was something about the direct
attempt to just communicate with someone else in real time,
you know,
just to sending them a message.
It's something that crystallized my thinking.
So what it turned out,
how did it crystallize your thinking?
Just nuts interrupt,
but was it the immediate feedback loop?
It was the idea that they have,
since teachers have since done lots of studies where they had kids write an
essay on something,
an assignment,
and then they would also be in,
started to write some email to a friend or something,
and then they would grade both of the compositions and they would find that
inevitably the email that the kids were writing was much better writing.
Because when you're trying to write a composition,
there's all these,
you know,
we have all these attitudes or expectations or there's,
there's this kind of a writerly sense.
There's there,
there's all this other garbage and luggage and baggage on top of that,
but when we're just trying to send an email,
we're just,
we're directly trying to communicate something and we're not fooling around.
We're not trying to be,
make it make literary,
literary all.
They would just direct stuff.
And so the writing there was always much more directed concrete because that's
the,
that's the usual thing that happens when you're trying to write as you're not
concrete enough,
but when your emails,
I call concrete.
And so it was getting out of the whole kind of writerly stuff and just pure
concrete communication that really made it for me.
And what I discovered,
which is what many writers discover,
is that I write in order to think.
It was like,
I think I have an idea,
but when I begin to write it,
I realized I have no idea.
And I don't actually know what I think until I tried to write it.
So writing is a way for me to define out what I think it's sort of,
it's like I don't have any idea if that's true,
but when I write I get the ideas and that was the revelation.
And so by being forced to communicate online and there was none of this
expectation,
it was just like,
okay,
this is ranting email.
I can do that.
I don't have to write an essay,
I don't want to write something nice.
I'm just going to write,
you know,
140 characters.
I can do that.
But while I was doing that,
I had an idea that it didn't have before.
And so it was like,
oh my gosh,
this is a idea generation machine.
It's by writing.
It's not that I have these ideas,
I'm going to write them down.
I don't know.
I don't even have them until I,
right.
I'm so glad you brought that up because I was just recently,
a few things related to that.
I was reading an interview with Kurt Vonnegut who's one of my favorite authors
for people who aren't familiar checkout cat's cradle perhaps as a starting
point.
Hilarious guy and he at various points in his career taught writing to make ends
meet and he would number one,
not look for good writers.
He would look for people who are passionate about specific things.
So that's,
that's something I want to reiterate to people who don't feel writerly.
Is that right?
Go out and have the experiences and find the subjects,
the things that excite you.
And as long as you're true to your voice,
which is related to the email point.
I throughout my first two drafts of that say a third of the four hour work week
because they were either too pompous and Ivy League sounding odd to way,
way,
way too much.
I mean a horrible or to slapstick because I felt like I had to go to the other
extreme and then I sat down and I wrote as if I were composing an email to a
friend after two glasses of wine and that's how I found my voice,
so to speak.
As a side note,
why,
and I think this might be related,
but why did you promise yourself not to teach English?
I'm so curious because that's a,
that can be very lucrative.
It's a readily available.
When you were traveling,
why did you commit to yourself not to teach English?
Yeah,
it's a good question because there was lots of opportunities all around the
world.
And by the way,
I recommend it as a way for people to travel cheaply if you went to support
yourself because it is a very desirable skill we call it for the moment.
I think the reason why was I felt that I didn't feel like I was a very good
teacher and I also felt that it was maybe a little easy,
but I think the main reason was that I was having trouble imagining myself
enjoying it,
you know?
And I just felt that I would rather try to find something else.
Now,
I think I did one time in Taiwan,
which as you know,
has a whole cram school system.
I think a friend,
a substitute for a friend once,
and I think that may be confirmed
that while it was there were sort of like,
you know,
all I have to do is this talk.
I mean there's really not much skill involved at all.
It was fun,
but I do feel like I was,
I don't know,
I didn't feel like I was maybe adding value or something.
So I came away thinking,
you know,
I guess I could do this for money,
but I'm not going to be happy.
I think it was just a personality thing.
I don't think of myself as a teacher.
I don't do many workshops or classes.
So I think a different person might thoroughly enjoy it and I know they do and
they have a great time doing it.
For me it was just not for me.
No big deal.
I think this is an important thing is,
is that,
you know,
it takes a long time to kind of figure out what you're good for and part of
where I'm at right now and where I got eventually was really trying to spend
time on doing things that only I can do and even when I can do something well,
but someone else could do it,
I would try and let that go.
That that's a discipline that I'm still working on,
which is not just things that I'm good at,
the things that only I'm good at.
So that was something I was sort of trying to start early on,
which is like,
you know,
a lot of other people can do this and they're happy doing it.
So I want to go somewhere where it requires of me to do and then I'll be happier
and they'll be happier.
I am currently having,
and I seem to have these periodically,
a crisis of meaning phase,
and I'm wrestling with this exact issue,
trying to figure out what to abandon,
what to say no to,
to refine my focus so I can really focus on the intersection of my unique
capability or capabilities,
whatever that is,
and a need of some type.
How did you figure that out?
And maybe we could approach it from a different direction.
What do you feel is your skillset or your,
your unique skill and how did you figure that out?
Well,
let me tell you the story of how this realization actually came to me in a kind
of a very concrete way was while I was editing wired magazine.
And so part of what wired magazine is about is,
is that we would come up with ideas and make assignments to writers.
Now,
some of the articles in wired would come from the writers themselves.
They would approach us to say,
I have an idea,
but a lot of the,
the articles would be assigned from editors.
We'd have editorial meetings where we kind of imagine this great article and
then we'd go and try and find someone to,
to write it.
And um,
in,
in that conversation of trying to persuade writers to write an idea that I had,
they would go through a kind of a very typical sequence where,
you know,
I would have this great idea,
this is a great idea.
And then I would try to persuade one writer,
two or three writers and they just,
they didn't think it was a very good idea.
They didn't like it,
they didn't want to do or whatever it was.
And then I'd kind of forget about it,
but then like,
you know,
six months later would come back and say,
oh,
that was such a great idea.
I really think we should do that.
And then I would go again for another round of trying to persuade people and
then I get no takers and then,
okay,
oh,
I forgot about that.
Must have been a bad idea.
But then like six months later or a year later,
my cut backing know that's still a great idea.
Nobody has done that.
And then I would realize,
oh my gosh,
I need to do that.
You know,
was like,
I'm the only one who can see this.
I've tried to give it away.
I have tried really hard to give it away.
I've tried to kill it.
It just keeps on coming back,
coming back.
And it's like,
okay,
then I would do it and there'll be one of my best pieces.
And so it was this idea of like,
so,
so I became really an important proponent of trying to give things away first.
Tell everybody what you're doing.
Basically,
you try to give these ideas away and people were happy cause they love great
ideas and you're,
hey,
do it.
It's a great idea.
You should do it.
And so,
um,
I try to give everything away first and then I tried to kill everything.
It's like,
no,
that's a bad idea.
And then it's the ones that keep coming back that I can't kill and they can't
give it away.
They think,
hmm,
maybe that's the one I'm supposed to do because no one else is going to do it.
I mean,
I've been,
actively trying to get,
and then of course if someone else is doing it,
you know,
you,
you should see someone else competing or trying to do it.
It's like,
oh yeah,
you go ahead do it.
I'm not going to race against you.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Because there's two of us,
you know,
you do it.
Um,
so that,
that generosity is actually part of this vetting process.
Exactly.
And so that's when I kind of realized it,
but that doesn't answer the question of well how do you find out what it is?
And all I can say is,
you know,
and I don't want to be flip,
but all I can say is this going to take all your life to figure that out.
That is fact.
Here's what,
here's what it is.
Figuring out is what your life is about.
That's what life is for.
Life is to figure it out.
And then every part of your life,
every day is actually does attempt to figure this out.
And you'll have different answers as you go along.
And sometimes there may be directions in that,
but that's basically what it is.
And you were very transparent about confessing this,
but I have to tell you that even from hanging around a lot of very accomplished
people,
a lot of successful people that we would be on the covers of magazines,
they also go through exactly the same questioning.
I mean,
no matter how big of $1 billion company and they have the,
they come up to the same thing.
Well you know what's,
what's my role in all this?
Why am I here?
What am I useful?
What am I doing that nobody else can?
And it's a,
it's a continuous,
in fact,
as we'll come back to being successful,
makes it even more difficult.
Why is that?
Because of the,
what I call the Creator's dilemma,
which is very much the same thing as the innovator's dilemma,
which is that there's a true dilemma.
In fact,
it in the sense that there's no right answer.
But the question is,
is sort of,
is it better to optimize your strengths or to invest into the unknown,
into places where you're weak and any places you haven't explored?
Yeah.
Any accountant and a business will tell you that it did.
Absolutely.
It makes more sense to take your dollar cause you'll get,
you'll get a higher return by investing into what you're good at already.
Whatever it is is the pursuit of excellence.
This is the Tom Peters and the whole entire movement,
which is you move up hill.
You,
you keep optimizing what you know.
And that by far is the sanest the most reasonable,
the,
the smartest thing to do.
But when you have a very fast changing landscape like we live in right now,
um,
you get stuck on a local Optima.
You get,
you get stuck.
And the problem is,
is that the only way you can get to a higher,
more fit place is you actually have to go down.
You have to have to head into a place where you are less optimal.
You have no expertise.
There's very low margins,
there's low profits.
You look foolish.
There'll be failures.
And if you've been following a line of success,
that is very,
very difficult to do.
It's very difficult for an organization.
It's almost literally almost impossible for an organization who's been
excellent,
successful to do it really is.
So,
which presents a lot of opportunity for,
that's why the startups,
the reason why startups start,
it's because they're operating in an environment that no same B corporation
would want to be in.
It's it's,
it's a market is low margins,
low profitability,
unproven,
high failure.
I mean it's like who was operated?
Nobody there.
Only reason why I started up software is they have no choice,
right?
Yeah.
It's the,
the gift of few options,
right?
Exactly.
So,
so,
so in terms of success binding,
I think you have to be unsuccessful.
Who is successful,
wants to be unsuccessful.
It's very,
very hard to,
to let go of that success.
And so that's one of the things that works against someone really continuing
the,
on this life journey of finding out what they're really good at.
Because,
because here's the thing is that successful companies and successful people
generally try to solve problems with money.
You buy solutions and we all know that money doesn't,
is not the full answer for innovation.
You know,
basically if you could purchase innovations,
all the big companies were just purchased them.
Okay.
It's,
it's the fact that these innovations often have to be found out without money
through other means.
Again,
that's the event is to the startup and it's a disadvantage to the successful
companies because they got money and they just want to buy solutions,
but you mostly solutions you can't buy.
You have to kind of engineer in this very difficult environment of low margins,
low success,
low profits that no one really wants to be in,
but startups are forced to be.
That's also an advantage I would think for beginners are novices compared to
your experts.
They have less vested identity,
less inertia to have to reverse.
And that goes back to my suggestion,
the meaning of why slack and fooling around when you're young is so important
because a lot of these innovations and things were found not trying to solve a
problem that can be monetized.
Yeah.
It's in exploring this area without money.
I mean money is so overrated.
It really.
Could you elaborate on that?
Cause I feel like this is a sermon I need to receive on some level.
There's several things to say about it.
One is,
you know,
obviously if you're struggling to pay bills and mortgages and stuff,
there's a certain amount that's needed,
but,
but here's the thing is that accumulating enough money to do things is really a
byproduct of other things.
It's a kind of a,
a lubricant in a certain sense rather than a,
you know,
a goal and great wealth or extreme wealth is definitely overrated.
I've had meals with a dozen billionaires and they're no different.
I mean their lives,
lifestyles are no different.
There are billions is you don't to have $1 billion.
I mean put it that way,
you really don't.
You can't.
There's nothing that you can really do with it that you can't do with a lot of
less money.
It was a set that aside,
but even just wealth itself in this world where there is more and more
abundance,
even the money for say middleclass is less significant in a certain sense in the
sense that maybe there's status which is really not needed,
but the things that you want to do,
the things that will make you contend to things that will satisfy you,
the things that will bring you meaning can usually got better than having money.
I mean if you have a lot of time or a lot of money is always better to have a
lot of time to do something.
And so if you have a choice between having a lot of friends or a lot of money,
you definitely want to have a lot of friends.
And so I think there's a way and even in which the technological progress that
we're having is actually diminishing the role of money.
And I wanted to be clear that I'm talking about money beyond the amount that you
need to survive.
But even that reflects back what we were saying earlier,
which is probably less than you think it is that you can to survive.
And so in a certain sense,
most people see money as a means to get these other things,
but there are other routes to these other things that are deeper and more
constant and more durable and more powerful.
So money is a sort of very small one dimensional thing that if you kind of focus
on that,
it kind of comes and goes.
And if you,
whatever it is that you're trying to attain,
you go to it more directly through other means.
You'll probably wind up with a more powerful experience or whatever it is that
you're after.
And it will be deeper,
more renewable than coming at it with money.
And so,
you know,
travel is one of the great examples is,
which is,
you know,
many,
many people who are working very hard trying to save their money to retire some
day to travel.
Well,
I decided to flip it around and travel when I was really young,
when I had zero money.
And you know,
I had experiences that basically even $1 billion couldn't have bought a
building.
And it's not an uncommon sight.
And let me tell you,
for young kind of travelers who had very little money to be hanging out doing
something,
and then there will be some very wealthy people on there one week organized tour
looking at these young travelers,
this saying,
I wish you,
I wish I had more time.
Yeah,
you see it,
you see it every,
well,
I see it almost every time I go traveling and it,
and it reminds me of conversations I've had with Rolf Potts and also his book
vagabonding,
which I just absolutely love.
And it was,
it was that book and Walden that I took with me traveling when I had my own two
years.
So a walkabout and he points out in the beginning of vagabonding that many
people subscribe to the belief along the of Charlie Sheen's in the movie Wall
Street [inaudible] when he's asked to what he's going to do when he makes his
millions and he says,
I'm going to get a motorcycle and ride across China.
And Ralph of course points out that you could,
you could clean toilets in the u s and save enough money to ride a motorcycle
across time.
And uh,
the,
uh,
let me ask you,
this is,
this is maybe tangentially related,
but you mentioned earlier that you know,
you're your Middle Age,
uh,
your middle ages,
the middle ages maybe sounds odd,
but in your middle age that's when you optimize.
And I find that horrifying on some level because I am so tired.
I just turned 37 last week and I'm,
I'm really tired of certain types of optimizing and the incremental slogging of
making trains run slightly more efficiently on time.
Even though,
like you said,
from a strictly financial standpoint,
the advice that I would receive for many people and have received when I've
asked for advice is here are one or two core areas you should focus on to
optimize for income.
And on the flip side I'm tempted to approach a kind of,
not scorched earth but burned bridges approach where I somehow use creative
destruction to force me into another direction to have these new experiences
that I crave so much and you just,
for people who aren't aware,
I want to give,
I remember going to the first ever quantified self meetup.
You're,
you're part of the long now foundation.
You've experimented in so many different arenas and have looked so far into the
future and thought on such grand a scale,
you know,
I aspire to do more of that.
What would be your advice to someone,
and I know I have dozens of friends in the same position,
they're saying in early or mid thirties in my particular peer group and they
want to explore,
but they're feeling pressured to optimize this thing that they've suddenly found
their footing with whatever it is.
Then maybe they're a venture capitalist,
maybe they're in a startup,
they feel they should start a new startup and they want to step out of that slip
stream.
What would be your advice to those people?
First of all,
I have to commend your honesty for this and I will repeat that,
that,
um,
it is very,
very difficult to do.
I mean,
I think that realization is,
you know,
comes to people in middle age and they realize,
oh my gosh,
you know,
I'm kind of on a,
there's a little bit of a routine here and I'm not really happy with that.
I think that kind of,
you know,
scorched earth to kind of like,
just,
we'll just set fire to it and we'll walk away.
I actually have,
I think we probably have a mutual friend.
I won't use his name because I don't know how,
how,
um,
how public this is.
But,
but one of the solutions was the most radical one I've ever heard force himself
was that he gave up US citizenship.
Oh Wow.
That'll do it.
It was like,
he was like saying,
I just feel so,
you know,
and,
and I was like,
oh my gosh,
that's so radical.
And he was telling me about what is involved in that.
And it wasn't for tax purposes because actually before you can do it,
the u s actually requires that you square up on all taxes.
Right.
It was like,
but that was so radical and I don't recommend that.
I mean he's,
he's doing fine,
but I'm just saying that's necessary.
But I think the advice is Bobby taking a page from yourself.
I don't think it's necessary to,
uh,
I,
I think you can experiment your way through this.
I mean,
you can do this incrementally.
You can,
you can take small steps and do something and then evaluated test how I was
going,
whether you're getting what you want out of it,
whether it's working and then you continue in that direction and that's sort of
the pattern of people who kind of,
you have second careers or reinvent themselves.
You hear that a lot and you can do that in a disciplined Tim Ferriss way.
I don't think that it requires you to kind of walk out and leave a burning pile
behind.
I think it's something that you're going to,
I'm a big believer in doing things deliberately.
And I think that you begin by looking at those areas that you get satisfaction
out of.
And those areas where I often find that people kind of retreat back to kind of
the things that they did as kids and really,
really missing,
whether it's art or other things.
And the truth is that you're not really going to be able to escape all the other
things you have going.
And that's good thing because I think that is part of you and part of what you
do well.
So you'll probably just,
you know,
bend in a certain direction.
And I think the one bit of advice is that you can't,
you know,
it's not gonna happen overnight.
It's going to be,
it took you 37 years to get where you are.
It may take you another 30 years to get where you want to go.
And I don't think you should feel impatient.
Maybe that's the word I'm saying is,
is that,
uh,
I don't think you should imagine that you'll have another hat on with a new
label,
you know,
next year
just to maybe redirect that,
and this may or may not be accurate,
but in the process of researching for this conversation,
which is sort of an odd exercises,
isn't in and of itself given how much time we've spent together.
But I came across in Wikipedia mention of your experience in Jerusalem and
deciding to live as though you only had six months left.
And I want to touch on that.
But one of the questions that came to my mind when I turned 37 last week is if I
knew I were going to die at age 40 what would I do to have the greatest impact
on the greatest number of people?
And so the,
I find that constraint helpful and I worry that if I aim it not being impatient
in that way,
that I won't because I could get hit by a bus that I won't do what I'm capable
of doing.
Maybe you could talk about,
and I had no idea,
I'm not sure if you would self describe yourself as a devout Christian,
but that's,
that's certainly written here.
Maybe you could talk a little bit about that experience.
Yeah.
So yeah,
one thing I would of course warn people is that not everything on Wikipedia is
correct.
No,
that's why I'm bringing it up.
But it is,
it's true that I got this assignment in Jerusalem,
which by the way,
if you want to hear the full version of it,
listen to one of the very first this American lives,
which I IRA glass.
And I told the story for the very first time and it's a story about how I got
this assignment to live as if I was going to die in six months,
even though I was like perfectly healthy.
And I knew that there was a very improbable,
but I decided to take the assignment seriously.
And that's,
that's what I did.
And my answer kind of surprised me because I thought that I would kind of have
this sort of mad,
high risk fling,
you know,
uh,
do all these things.
But actually what I wanted to do was to visit my brothers and sisters,
go back to my parents,
help out with them.
My mom was not well at a time,
but that lasted for three months before I decided I need to do something big.
So I actually rode my bicycle across the u s from San Francisco to New York
where I was going to New Jersey where I was going to basically die.
And I kept a journal of that.
And that question was something that I keep asking myself.
Now I actually have a countdown clock that Matt Groening,
Futurama was inspired and they did a little episode on the future arm are about.
And what I did was I took the actuarial tables for the estimated age of my death
for someone born when I was born.
And I work back the number of days and I have,
I have that showing on my computer how many days?
And I tell you nothing,
constantly traits your time,
like knowing how many days you have left.
No,
of course I'm likely again to live more than that.
I mean good health,
etc. But nonetheless,
there was something that really,
you know,
I have 6,000 something days is not very many days to do all the things I want to
do.
And so I think your exercise is really fantastic and commendable and there's two
questions.
What do you,
what would you do if at six months living,
what would you do if he hit $1 billion?
And interestingly is the convergence of those two questions because it turns out
that you probably don't need $1 billion to do whatever it is you're going to do
in six months.
Right?
And so I think you're asking the right question.
And,
and the way I answer it is you want to keep asking yourself that question every,
every six months and really try to answer it.
And I tried to,
you know,
do that on a kind of a day by day basis.
I learned something from my friend Stewart brand who organized his remaining
days around five year increments.
He says,
any great idea that's significant,
that's worth doing for him?
Well,
it lasts about five years from the time he thinks of it til the time we stopped
thinking about it.
And if you think of it in terms of five year projects,
you can count those off on,
you know,
a couple of hands for even if you're young.
And so the sense of mortality of,
of understanding that it's not just old people who don't have very many,
you know,
you're,
you're 20 years old,
you don't have that many five year projects to do.
And so I think it is,
that's maybe part of the philosophy of thinking about our time and whether you,
even if you believe in the extension of life longevity living to 120 you still
have to think in these terms of what are you gonna do for you?
Cause you're new.
You don't know if you'll live on 120 what are you going to do if you have a year
and what would you do with $1 billion?
And what's the intersection of those two?
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes or go to for our blog.com
where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much,
much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com slash t Ferriss.
That's Tim Prri access or on Facebook at facebook.com/tim Ferriss.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.